[Musique]
ça les enfants bosso un bon soir mais
oui ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à nicolas et pimprenelle une
histoire qu'ils aiment beaucoup dibi
dibi dont l'échelle est
tombé début du but du début tu
bon soit il
nous raconte une histoire himmich tas de
filippi wii 2 philippines et du lapin
blanc aux eaux sont pauvres lapin blanc
il a bien des malheurs
un instant je me pose
là
écoutez bien
dit midi tibi dit le lapin blanc
toujours très en colère construisent un
mur un mur très haut tout autour du jard
d'appoint comme ça c'est vilain loire ne
pourront plus venir me prendre mes
belles phrases
auj et quand il eut terminé son ouvrage
il se cachera derrière un arbre avec son
amie philippine
tu sais ils n'ont pas l'air si vilain
disait la petite fille quand tout-à-coup
qui virent t-il sur le toit de la maison
nu tout d'abord le papa loire suivi de
près par un deux trois quatre
toute la famille au grand complet
comme tout semblait calme tranquillement
ils descendirent le long du mur que le
lapin blanc venait de construire et
prirent chacun une grosse fraise euros
[Musique]
oui hop hop hop hop hop hop tibi grondal
lapin blanc en colère attendu que je
vous attrape
nom laisse là ils sont si mignons
s'écria philippines en tapant sur son
tambour
les petits loi étonné regardèrent
philippines qui disparurent bien vite
derrière leur papa de l'autre côté du
mur
et cela sauf le plus petit qui était si
maladroit qu'il n'arrivait pas à grimper
jusqu'en haut en voilà et qui vit du
monde
heureusement philippines arriva devant
lui elle pris le bébé loire et ouvrit la
porte du jardin
[Musique]
va petit loire retourne choqué par an et
10 lors que je vous trouve très gentil
et que je suis votre ami
le petit loire se sauva très vite après
avoir posé sur le nez de la petite fille
un baiser de loi
et voilà les enfants l'histoire est
terminée qu'est ce qui vous fait la
prochaine fois les loire vous verrez
vous verrez tu nous donnes le livre oui
données merci à présent nous allons y
chers petits
belle migraine un gentil bonne ni les
enfants fêtes de beaurains
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
du but du début du début du mas parole
mais c'est le lapin blanc bono patron
c'est moi nounours
je vous ai attrapé allons en route gro
farseth bonne eu des enfants allez vite
vous couchez les fêtes de bourg eux
[Musique]
oui
on